hello it's New Year's Eve apparently and
what better way to end the year than to
revisit some longevity highlights sounds
good right it does doesn't it for most
of the topics I already made videos on
or I spoke with someone about it so I
will create a playlist below and add it
to the end of the video uh so if you
want more details it will be there this
video inide is more of the big summary
but it also includes new content so you
should hang about so firstly the
universe is
expanding well I mean actually is EA
physics but I mean here about the
Hallmarks of Aging the Hallmarks of
Aging describe different biological
features that occurr in all organisms
that experience biological aging and are
used to help us understand the aging
process now I have said it before to
some people I don't remember if on this
channel that the Hallmark active aging
needed updating particularly for me to
include the G microbiome and cadium
rhythms and well look it now includes
three more Hallmarks disbiosis
disabled macro autophagy and chronic
inflammation now I'm not sure if this
has helped people understand aging any
better and to me it still seems to be
highly degenerative but I am glad to see
that disbiosis made the list but
speaking of what causes aging there was
a nice paper that came out earlier this
year describing the role of the dream
complex which sounds very nice but it's
a complex that inhibits the expression
of DNA repair enzymes so maybe not quite
the dream that we want it to be anyhow
in this paper they showed that
inhibition of the dream complex in human
cells boosted DNA repair gene expression
and resistance to distinct DNA damag
types how
compelling so the Hallmarks are there to
help us understand what aging is but how
do we quantify it well a
BC I mean the Aging B marker Consortium
of
course this Consortium the Aging B
marker Consortium raises some
interesting points about biomarkers that
it must be specific as in the rate of
Aging rather than the pathological
effects it must be systemic when
combined a group of biomarkers should
reflect multi-dimensional changes in
certain systems and it must be
serviceable for translation into
clinical practice anyhow the ABC is
China's effort to
contribute slightly Switching gears
today I had my eyes tested and while
looking at eyes can help us decide if we
need to wear glasses they can also
potentially be used as a biological age
proxy while everyone is hyper focused
with DNA inflation in this e life paper
that came out this year researchers at
The Bu Institute showed that Imaging of
the fundus the blood vessel Rich tissue
in the retina can be used to track human
Aging in a way that is non invasive less
expensive and potentially more accurate
than other agent clocks that are
currently
available in addition these retinal
scans are less likely to be influenced
by day-to-day fluctuations compared to
other biomarkers from the blood which
are more Dynamic and can be influenced
by something such as what we eat so this
paper quite literally puts the fun in
fundus and with artificial intelligence
as well it seems like there is much
information that can be exploited from
these retinal images here using
self-supervised
learning but maybe in the future we
don't even need to take photos will be
wearing these smart contact lenses not
sure about that but speaking of eyes I
buy something with my eye beginning with
s subscribe anyway speaking of
biomarkers I recently spoke with Aaron
King about his hot takes and biomarkers
and his recent tool that he's build to
actually look at different factors that
change of age and that video will be
released whenever I find time to edit
it so moving on let's look at cellular
reprogramming so in this first paper
byon CL loss of epigenetic information
as a cause of mamalian Aging what they
did was create a mouse model where they
could induce Aging in the epig genome
using an approach that initially caused
DNA damage and then what they
subsequently show is that they could
express some of the yo factors OCT 4 so
2 and K left for to refer some of the
changes that they had induced this is
quite a complex study to understand so I
actually do recommend in this case
watching a video that I made on it
before and then another paper that came
out from his lab this year was about
chemically inuse reprogramming again
this is another topic I've discussed in
much more detail before but essentially
instead of using the expression of genes
and cells to cause the Rejuvenation here
you're causing reprogramming by using
different chemicals my naive
understanding of this paper is that it
was more developing an assay that they
could then use to see what chemicals
might work however the chemicals they
tested have already been shown in other
studies but I probably will revisit this
topic at some point because I think for
scalin is quite interesting as a
compound and continuing with St Cloud's
lab you may remember that two years ago
there was a lot and I mean a lot of
excitement over the restoration of
vision in Old mice when they delivered
the OS
factors and well now we have some even
more exciting news which is from a model
that is even closer to humans life
biosciences a biotechnology company
advancing Innovative cellular
Rejuvenation Technologies to refers
diseases of aging and injury and
ultimately restore health for patients
today or whenever this article came out
announced preclinical data in non-human
primates for its novel gene therapy
candidate which uses a partial
epigenetic reprogramming approach to
restore fual function and the data looks
promising and while The Limited Insight
we get from this is that the data looks
like it was successful so that is good
news but while it is good news it's also
important to discuss concerns with
cellular reprogramming using the
yamanaka factors take this paper in fivo
reprogramming leads to premature death
linked with hepatic and intestinal
failure it doesn't sound good but
actually it's not all bad it's really
quite informative essentially when you
have continuous expression of the amaca
factors in all tissues of the mice it
equals bad there was liver and
intestinal dysfunction the mice were not
happy and I don't blame them but when
they avoided expression in the liver and
intestine of the yamac factors there was
a decrease in biological
age I think there is something really
interesting to say on this work so stay
tuned For an upcoming
video anyhow this brings me more
generally to lifespan extension and
Rejuvenation firstly we have some new
updates from the interventions testing
program and for those of you who don't
know the interventions testing program
or ITP essentially is a massive program
that test different compounds in
genetically diversed mice to see if it
extends their lifespan so the main
priority is looking at lifespan as
opposed to health
Biometrics in their genetically diverse
mice beginning treatment at 12 months of
age they noted this year that the Nrf2
Activator asanin extended the median
male lifespan by 12% the mtalk 1
inhibitor
mcine extended male lifespan by
8% neither of them impacted the lifespan
of the female
myu other compounds they tested that
didn't extend lifespan included fistin a
potential analytic that I've done a deep
dive on before as
g1002 a hydrogen sulfide donor dimethyl
ferates micop phenolic acids and four
phal
beades I don't really know much about
any of these last compounds I just
mentioned maybe I will in the future but
for now let's move on to a different
compound toine toine is a compound
naturally found within the body and it
is an amino acid however it is not
incorporated into proteins instead it
seems to perform a variety of different
functions within the body and torine
concentrations are known to decline in
the blood with age and what this paper
showed that came out in the summer was
that a rsal of this drop by torine
supplementation increased healthy
lifespan in mice and worms and
positively impacted several Hallmarks of
Aging in humans lower torine
concentrations are associated with
multiple diseases and a randomized
controlled clinical trial in humans
is now needed to assess the anti-aging
effects of toine now I spoke with one of
the researchers behind the study until
I'll link to that video in my
playlist another study that showed
lifespan extension and mice though this
time with an inhibitor of the protein
pi3 kise or pi3 k a protein involved in
signaling Downstream of insulin and the
insulin light grow factor receptor both
of which are associated with longevity
already provided evidence in this paper
that treatment with this inhibitor of
ph3 K Al pelis from middle age can
extend the median and maximal lifespan
of mice and while the pi3 kyes and Hippa
treatment improved some markers of
Health span including strength and
balance and coordination it didn't
impact other biomarkers of Aging like
hypoglycemia cognition card vascular
function and bone mass nonetheless it
would be interesting now to see if this
p3y inhibitor or the use of torine has
any impact on lifespan in the ITP
studies so this paper came out right at
the start of the year and it
demonstrated a cool approach known as
optogenetic
Rejuvenation let's quickly illuminate
what went on the way ATP is generated in
cells is through the generation of a
proton motive Force essentially a high
concentration of protons hydrogen ions
in the space between the membranes of
the mitochondrial
organel when these protons move down the
concentration gradient out of the space
between the membranes they go through a
protein called ATP synthes the movement
of protons through this protein
facilitates the generation of ATP the
energy source of the cell in this paper
they describe a tool called mitochondria
on a tool that also moves protons across
the membrane but they can activate it in
the presence of light and so when they
activated this tool in
worms to keep a high proton motive Force
they were able to influence the life SP
of the worms I interviewed Brandon all
about his paper so I recommend you
checking out that one as well continuing
with longevity there was also this
interesting paper about engineering
longevity designing a synthetic Gene
oscillator to slow down the aging
process and this was conducted in yeast
where yeast have two switches that can
lead them to die one causes death by
nuclea decline the other by
mitochondrial decline by rewiring or
shall I say re-engineering this pathway
and this switch in inste into a negative
feedback loop the authors were able to
cause the ye cells to oscillate between
these two death States and increase
their lifespan by 82%
quite impressive what's also impressive
is the fact that my family always teased
me about the fact that my favorite film
was fatui but speaking of rats we found
out this year that the longest lived
spog DOI rat was documented Roland SEMA
a rat that underwent injections of blood
plasma taken from pigs that has now been
described as being concentrated plasma
fraction that includes exell physicals
that had many benefits in terms of Dame
infation and other biomarkers to the
health of these rats I also described
this in another
video but speaking of blood Dory are you
okay there was this paper that came out
in the summer that evaluated the
long-term treatment of heterochronic
parabiosis the procedure by which two
different individuals share a
circulatory system so they repeat in a
study what is somewhat already
understood which is that pairing an old
Mouse with a young Mouse increases the
lifespan compared with the old fuse with
an old mouse but now we have further
support for this coming from DNA mation
data but is heterochronic parabiosis
practical for
humans I think
not exactly uh so let's move on to
biotechnology and one paper that I
covered this year that I really feel
like was undervalued was this one on
infusible
biomaterial effectively isolating
components of the extracellular Matrix
from tissue samples removing all of the
cells doing some digestion and
fractionation and then injecting it back
and what they show in this paper is that
in mouth models of acute myocardial
infection traumatic brain injury and
Pulmonary arterial
hypertension adding back this infusible
extracellular Matrix filled the gaps
between the endial cells that become
damaged in these different diseases
effectively repairing the tissue very
interesting
technology another paper that was very
compelling was one that described a new
collagen replacement therapy that was
applied to the skin of mice and improved
long-term treatment of photoage skin
here they delivered it fora
extracellular physicals containing Co 1
A1 mRNA that includes the information to
generate
collagen and it may be an effective
protein replacement therapy for the
treatment of photo a
skin now we' spoken a lot about what
causes aging and how we might be able to
fix it but another question that's worth
asking is but why do we
age so there were a few articles that
came out this year that sort of reflect
on this question one paper that is quite
compelling discusses aging as a software
design floor the idea that aging is in
fact programmed and more recently one of
the authors of this paper published a
provocatively titled refie the longevity
bottleneck hypothesis could dinosaurs
have shaped aging and present day
mammals based on the observation that
reptiles age slower their mammals could
it be that the 100 million years when
dinosaurs cohabited the Earth with early
small mammals that it placed a strong
selection pressure on the mammals to
have a shorter lifean and to reproduce
more
quickly speaking of selection pressures
I also learned this year of the pathogen
control evolutionary hypothesis
primarily put forward by Peter litsky
according to this hypothesis a shorter
lifespan might have evolved to eliminate
older individuals who are more likely to
carry chronic sterilizing pathogens I
interviewed Peter about this Theory so I
recommend watching that to learn more
about the evidence that supports this
Theory and speaking of infections it
seems that blood group a enhances covid
infection which is linked with how blood
groups are defined by antigens on the
red blood cells these antigens are used
in communication between cells and an
entire area that I just think is
underexplored in general so what's on
the horizon well I feel currently we're
still yet to really witness the impact
of AI on the progress made in longevity
I think that we could see some
interesting human clinical trials be
conducted within the next year some more
stuff on replacement aging which I need
to do some more research on myself and
also I want to do some deep dives into
fertility as I'm currently reading quite
a bit about it I so the last news that I
will leave you with is that I actually
defended myis the the end of this month
December yes so I will officially be a
doctor Shiki at some
so I foresee another chaotic crazy but
catastrophically amazing year ahead and
I will do my best to keep posting but I
also have some big life changes
happening and decisions that I need to
make so ultimately I just love making
the videos and will continue to do so
most likely so happy New Year and check
out this video here if you want to see
the Deep Dives that did in most of the
topics that I've mentioned in this video